ultimately the ability to learn a
language
is it still comes down to the three keys
that i refer to so often hi there
steve kaufman here today i want to talk
about
the role of talent in language learning
uh remember if you enjoy these videos
please
subscribe and click on the bell for
notifications
so if any of you out there
have learned even one or more languages
to a fairly
decent level you have undoubtedly had
people tell you
you have a talent for languages and the
people who say this to you
are typically people who don't speak
other
languages someone who already speaks two
or three languages
is unlikely to say that because they
know that learning another language
takes a lot of effort
so the typical person who says you have
a talent for language
either hasn't put a lot of effort into
learning a language or is stuck with a
method of language acquisition which
isn't very efficient
they go to the library language spanish
class three times a week or something
people who are successful at language
learning they typically
will do a lot of listening and reading
and put a lot of effort
uh i mean very few people will do what i
do which is to get up every morning and
listen to
whatever language i'm learning and
listen an hour a day while working out
while cleaning up
and do a lot of reading and put in an
hour or two every day
into language learning few people do
that so
typically people who say you just have a
talent for language
uh are kind of trying to justify the
fact that they haven't been
willing to put that degree of effort or
to look for more efficient ways of
learning
but is there a talent for language
learning i think it's possible
that there are very varying degrees of
ability
to learn another language and a number
of things
influence that first of all the more
languages you know
the better you become at learning
languages your brain is more flexible
you are more open to new sounds new
structures you don't resist the new
language
you're more confident that you can do it
you have some ideas of
of methods that for language learning
that work
at least for you so you're a better
language learner
so so that's obviously going to
influence but that's not so much talent
as as ability it's not sort of an
inherent talent for language learning
another thing that influences our
ability to learn is is the degree to
which we're exposed to the language
so if you go to sweden where kids watch
television in english and listen to
english language you know pop music and
so forth they have so much exposure to
english before they start
that in sweden just about everybody
speaks english so
is it that the english that the swedes
have some gene for language learning i
don't think so
and it's similar in other places where
people are exposed to
a lot of languages like in singapore or
apparently in ethiopia although i've
never been there
so the amount of exposure you get in
influences your ability to learn a
language
but that's not necessarily the same as
talent
uh i think ultimately
the ability to learn a language is it
still comes down to the three keys that
i refer to so often
the attitude of the learner time spent
with the language
and the ability to notice and i'll leave
a link to a
video that i just did on the subject of
noticing and language acquisition
but obviously attitude as i said someone
who's learned
a few languages has a positive attitude
they think language learning is
worthwhile doing
worthwhile spending a lot of time at
they're confident that they will
achieve success typically they like the
language they're learning
so these attitude factors are much more
important than any
potential differences in talent
the same with time you can't learn
languages without putting in the time
some people are willing more willing to
put in time
than others uh noticing is something
that comes with
a good attitude and putting in the time
so you know my point really is it's a
bit like the discussion
can older people learn languages like
here i am 75
is a 20 year old a better language
learner than i am no it doesn't really
matter
it doesn't really matter we can all
learn even if we assume
that some people are more talented or
that a 20 year old is better than a 75
year old
it doesn't mean that a potentially less
talented person
can't learn if this theoretically less
talented person
has a good attitude is interested in the
language likes the language believes
that
learning the language is worthwhile
doing believes they're going to get
there
believes in the method they're using uh
and if that person puts in the time
and then develops you know is really
keen on noticing what's happening in the
language
that person will learn and if that
person is slightly less talented and
talented than someone else maybe not as
good at
imitating the sounds or or at
remembering vocabulary that person will
still learn
so to tell someone who has learned three
or four languages
oh you're just talented in languages um
that's a cough out because that
very person who's saying oh you're just
talent like i'm not
you are if they were to
have a positive attitude put in the time
be be motivated to notice what's
happening in that language to accept
that language rather than resisting it
that person will learn and if you take
10 people
some will learn better than others some
will pronounce better than others
some will speak better than others
but those differences are relatively
small compared to the differences
that come from the sort of differences
in attitude
differences in time spent differences in
methods used for language learning so
therefore i would dismiss talent
as an important consideration in
language learning
uh it's something that even if there are
differences we can't control those
differences
but what we can control is our attitude
the time we spend and to some extent
flowing from that
our ability to notice what's happening
in the new language and therefore to
acquire that language or several more
languages
so there you have it that's my take on
on talent and language learning and
i i suggest you have a look at the
video i did on noticing and look forward
to your comments
thank you bye for now